trop c'est inutile d'idiot enfin comment
dire est de toute façon ça sert à rien
je trouve que de toute façon les gens se
réuniront quand même chez eux ils à la
fête se fera ailleurs ça ne pose aucun
problème
d'abord parce que je sens pas donc ça
c'est une première raison est ensuite il
faut bien lutter contre le virus donc ça
me paraît tout à fait raisonnable
franchement je trouve ça un petit peu
ridicule parce que pour moi il aurait
fallu prendre largement avant clairement
donc bon après on n'a pas trop le choix
s'est fait rentrer plus tôt mais au
niveau clientèle et niveau commercial
c'est pas une bonne idée
je suis pour pour la vie de famille je
suis contre parce que d'un point de vue
professionnel c'est handicapant non bah
voilà comme nous on a moins de de
contamination que les autres que
d'autres départements d'ile-de-france et
du coup bah on aurait pu nous être un
peu plus léger sur moi j'appelle ça une
sanction